continuing on the sentencing phase just
wrapped up for the day for the box truck
driver who killed five
cyclists in december right near
searchlight 45 year old jordan varsity
admitted he was
under the influence of methamphetamine
when he ran
into a group of cyclists on u.s 95 joe
mohler was in the courtroom where
relatives of victims shared their
struggles without their loved ones
brian it was an emotional day in court
today we heard of from some of the
family of the victims and the accused
jordan barson
back in april barson entered a plea
agreement reducing the number of charges
he was facing to two counts of dui
resulting in death
family of some of the victims described
how the sudden deaths of their loved
ones changed their lives
douglas murray the brother of michael
murray looked at barson expressing his
loss
you can also see farson's reaction
jordan barson
there are no words there are no words
to express what you've done to our
family
what you did to my brother i can't
imagine him laying out there in the
road looking at the carnage
that this man created
at the start of the sentencing hearing
barson stood up via video and said he
was sorry and that
he was ashamed with himself he says
after he gets out of prison he wants to
share his
story at rehab facilities prevent
another tragedy like this now barson
faces up to 40 years
in jail we will hear from more family
members when the sentencing continues
tomorrow reporting live outside the
courthouse jill mullen 8 news now